so how difficult is it to create a
self-replicating assembler
self-replicating machine that builds
copies of itself but builds more
complicated version of itself which is
kind of the dream towards which you're
pushing in a generic arbitrary sense I
had a student Nadia Peak with Jonathan
Ward who who for me started this idea of
how do we use the tools in my lab to
make the tools in the lab yes uh in a
very clear sense they are making
self-reproducing machines so one of the
really cool things that's happened is
there's a whole network of machine
Builders around the world so there's
Danielle and now in Germany and yens in
Norway and
um each of these people is has learned
the skills to go into a Fab Lab and make
a machine and so we've started creating
a network of superfap so the Fab Lab can
make a machine but it can't make a
number of the Precision parts of the
machine so in places like Bhutan or
Carol in the south of India we started
creating super Fab Labs that have more
advanced tools to make the parts of the
machines so that the machine machines
themselves become even cheaper
so that that is self-reproducing
machines but you need to feed it things
like bearings or microcontrollers they
can't make those parts but other than
that they're making their own things and
I should note as a footnote the stack I
described of computers controlling
machines to machine making machines to
assemblers to self-assemblers view that
as fab1234
so we're transitioning from fab one to
Fab two and the research in the lab is
three and four at this Fab two stage a
big component of this is uh
sustainability in the material
feedstocks so Alicia colleague in Chile
is leading a great effort looking at how
you take um Forest Products and coffee
grounds and seashells and a range of
locally available materials and produce
the high-tech materials that go into the
lab
so all of that is machine building today
then
back in the lab what we can do today is
we have robots that can build structures
and can assemble more robots that build
structures
we have finer resolution robots that can
build micro mechanical systems so robots
that can build robots that can walk and
manipulate and we're just now we have a
project
at the layer below that where there's
endless attention today to billion
dollar chip Fab Investments uh but a
really interesting thing we passed
through is today the smallest
transistors you can buy as a single
transistor just commercially for
electronics is actually the size of an
early transistor in an integrated
circuit
so we're using these machines making
machines making assemblers to place
those parts to not use a billion dollar
chip Fab to make integrated circuits but
actually assemble little electronic
components so I have a fine enough
precise enough actuators and
manipulators that allow you to place
these transistors right that's a
research project in my lab
on discrete assembly of integrated
electronics and we're just at the point
to really start to take seriously this
notion of not having a chip Fab make
integrated Electronics but having not a
3D printer but a thing that's a cross
between a pick and place makes circuit
boards in 2D the 3D printer extrudes in
3D we're making sort of a micro
manipulator that acts like a printer but
it's placing to build Electronics in 3D
but this micromanipulator is distributed
so there's a bunch of them or is this
one centralized so that's why that's a
great question so um I have a prize
that's almost but not been claimed for
the students whose thesis can walk out
of the printer
oh nice so you have to print the thesis
with the means to to exit the printer
and it has to contain its description of
the thesis that says how to do that
it's a really good uh I mean it's a it's
a it's a fun example exactly the thing
we're talking about and I've had a few
students almost
get to that
um and so
um in what I'm describing there's this
stack where we're getting closer but
it's still quite a few years to really
go from us so there's a layer below the
transistors where we assemble the base
materials that become the transistor
we're now just at the edge of assembling
the transistors to make the circuits
we can assemble the micro parts to make
the micro robots we can assemble the
bigger robots and in the coming years
we'll be patching together all of those
uh scales so do you see a vision of just
endless billions of robots at the
different scales self-assembling
um self-replicating and building the
complicated structures yes and the butt
to the yes but is let me clarify two
things one is that immediately
raises King Charles fear of gray goo of
runaway mutant self-reproducing things
the reason why there are many things I
can tell you to worry about but that's
not one of them is if you want things
taught autonomously self-reproduce and
take over the world that means they need
to compete with nature on using the
resources of nature of water and
sunlight and in light of everything I'm
describing biology knows everything I
told you every single thing I explain
biology already knows how to do
um uh what I'm describing isn't new for
biology it's new for non-biological
systems so in the digital era the
economic win ended up being centralized
the big platforms
in this world of machines that can make
machines I'm a Mass for example
um you know what what's the killer
opportunity you know who's going to make
all the money
um who to invest in but if the machine
can make the machine it's not a great
business to invest in the machine
in the same way that if you can produce
if you can think globally but produce
locally then the way the technology goes
out into society isn't a function of
central control but is fundamentally
distributed now that that raises an
obvious kind of concern which is well
doesn't this mean you could make bombs
and guns and all of that
the reason that's much less of a problem
than you would think is making bombs and
guns and all of that is a very well met
Market need anywhere we go there's a
fine supply chain for weapons now
hobbyists have been making guns for ages
and guns are available just about
anywhere so you could go into the lab
and make a gun today it's not a very
good gun and guns are easily available
and so generally we run these lab in war
zones what we find is
people don't go to them to make weapons
which you can already do anyway it's an
alternative to making weapons it coming
back to your question I'd say the single
most important thing I've learned is
the greatest natural resource of the
planet is this amazing density of
Brighton event of people whose brains
are underused and
um you could view the the social
engineering of this lab work is creating
the capacity for them and so it you know
in the end the way this is going to
impact Society isn't going to be command
and control it's how the world uses it
and it's been really gratifying for me
to see just how it does